from chapter 10 of a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century
what is school for children school can
be understood as love and parenting
commodified
put another way part of what school is
is parenting that has been outsourced we
have already seen many of the harms and
risks of reductionism yet one more is
that reductionism facilitates the
commodification of easily quantifiable
things while tending to ignore those
things that are less quantifiable
thus school becomes about metrics how
much how fast how well did the little
one read do their multiplication tables
memorize a poem
it should go without saying that there
is clear and enduring value in reading
multiplication and poetry a focus on
speed and quantity is an error however
with me what myriad things are not being
learned in school because they succumb
less easily to reductionist assessments
school is based on an economic
efficiency while being unimaginative
about what could be accomplished the
economics not to mention the perverse
incentives behind compulsory schooling
of school tend to fill children's heads
with knowledge without showing them a
path to wisdom
perhaps school should serve the purpose
of helping young people grapple with the
question who am i and what am i going to
do about it that incidentally that the
footnote there is to derek jensen's
excellent book on education
another way of phrasing this might be
what's the biggest and most important
problem i can solve with my gifts and
skills or how do i find my consciousness
my truest self done well then school can
provide a great platform for formalizing
and delivering rights of passage
rather than focusing on any version of
these questions though modern schooling
especially the compulsory sort
widespread across the weird world is
more apt to teach quiescence and
conformity
what if we took as one of the goals of
school teaching children how to
understand and hack their own incentive
structures
knock them off the low adaptive peaks
that they are surely on i'm not good at
math languages or sports or conversely
i'm so good at math languages sports
that other things fail to grab my
attention
what if we knock them off those low
adaptive peaks into valleys that are
uncomfortable
but from where there are many possible
peaks to climb
or perhaps school should reveal to
children that fringe positions should be
explored and considered not thrown out
immediately on the basis that they are
unpopular
betting against the fringe is an easy
bet usually a safe one and when done in
a tone of paternalistic indulgence say
or authoritarian disdain it usually
shuts down descent
while most fringe ideas are in fact
wrong it is exactly from the fringe that
progress is made
this is where the paradigm shifts happen
this is where innovation and creativity
occur and yes most of it is wrong or
useless but the most important ideas on
which we now base our understanding of
the world and our society came from the
fringe
the sun is the center of the solar
system species adapt their environments
over time
humans can create technology that allows
us to communicate across time and space
to fly to create and explore virtual
worlds
these were all impossible ideas
laughable at the time
those who quickly join in laughing at
all fringe ideas now
would have been laughing at all of those
ideas in their time
school should be fun
but it should not be gameable
a child shouldn't be able to win at
school although many do and many more
lose at it
social rules and mores are learned at
school but at its base school should be
about discovering truth both universal
and local
school is for better and for worse a
standing for parents for kin group for
those with whom the child has shared
fate
schools should not therefore teach
through fear
risk and challenge help children learn
as with parenting this requires early
tight bonding during which a secure base
is established which provides children
the confidence to go out adventuring
fairly early because they know that
someone has their back no matter what
school that operates by fear will teach
the opposite lesson
fear is an easy mechanism of control and
so it should not be surprising that
teachers use fear to control students of
all ages
as corporal punishment in the classroom
fell out of favor in many but not all
places psychological and emotional
control replaced it it leaves fewer
marks
children are threatened with poor grades
poor test scores and having their
parents inform that they have behaved
badly which most children will hear as
you're a bad person
the rise of metrics within a system
which are often overly simple
wrong-headed and only
pseudo-quantitative
tends to accompany a decay in social
trust
how can good teachers stuck in a system
of escalating metrics imposed from the
outside counteract the prevailing
cultural forces
one approach which will be more
effective with older children and young
adults is for teachers to explicitly
hand away their own authority by telling
students not to trust them just because
they are the figure in the front of the
room
when a teacher then does earn the
respect and the trust of her students
such that she becomes a legitimate
authority figure one with authority that
was earned rather than assumed her
authority will better serve both the
students and their education
using fear to keep children seated in
neat and tidy rows to keep their eyes
forward and their mouths closed to keep
them from moving their bodies at all but
for a few scheduled moments in each day
this will help create adults who are
unable to regulate their own bodies and
senses
unable to trust in their own ability to
make decisions and likely to demand
similarly controlled environments in
their adult lives trigger warnings safe
spaces and the like
for young school children one solution
would be having a garden at school and
spending time in it in all sorts of
weather
frequent field trips to natural areas
and spending time actually outside
rather than in the climate-controlled
protection of the nature center will
help too
will it always be comfortable no
will some children be ill-prepared for
rain or wind or sun
yes
will they learn from small early
mistakes to start taking responsibility
for their own bodies and fates and so
get better at navigating the world yes
yes they will
humans are anti-fragile exposure to
discomfort and uncertainty physical
emotional intellectual is necessary
preparing students to understand risk it
encourages them to expand their world
views and embrace experiences that lead
to maturity this does however come at a
cost
sorry i lost it understanding risk
cannot completely protect individuals
from danger
in short risk is risky tragedies will
happen and that's no minor thing for
those of us who have been lucky to avoid
it it's nearly impossible to imagine how
a person continues on if their child has
died or if they have been involved in
someone else's child dying
tragedies that happen because someone
introduced risk into a school trip are
easy to point to
the story is often easy to tell and
compelling to hear
by contrast population level tragedies
those that happen because hull swathes
the population have difficulty
navigating risk and so avoided at all
costs this is also a tragedy and much
further
reaching modern school tends to protect
against individual tragedies while
facilitating the larger societal ones
arrange all little boys and girls neatly
in rows assign them seats and tell them
never to speak unless they are called on
first because that will make it easier
to keep track of them
at the same time at home teach the
little boys and girls that they are each
the center of the entire universe and
that they may and in fact should
interrupt adults at any moment for any
reason
teach the children that temper tantrums
are acceptable by caving to them
whenever they erupt and also tell the
children that they are the most precious
and infallible beings in existence and
as such any criticism is a crime against
their core selves
we should not be surprised when children
raised this way can make no sense of the
confused and confusing messages coming
at them from home and from school nor
should it surprise us when they
gravitate to the systems that are most
gameable
mom doesn't like it when i scream or
whine but if i persist at it she gives
in as a way to make me stop
noted
teacher leaves me alone if i
occasionally contribute a comment in
class and earn good grades even though
i'm learning nothing by regurgitating
from a textbook
got it
congratulations society you've
successfully produced self-satisfied
whiners who are accustomed to getting
what they want who are good at school
but not at thinking and who are in fact
neither smart nor wise
one and a half page excerpt
from again the school chapter of a
higher um a hunter gatherer's guide to
the 21st century
this section is called the world is not
about you
from the school chapter
children have been harmed through
through gnome oh boy
the world did i mention that the cat
drank my water
here i have some i would yes i would
love some of your water because um you
did not put your paw in this no
not even once
thank you much better
the world is not about you
children have been harmed through no
fault of their own by a perfect storm of
societal factors that emerged in the
late 20th and early 21st century which
we have already reviewed
the rise of pharmaceuticals being
prescribed to children
helicopter and snowplow parenting and
the near ubiquity of screens never mind
what is on them have all made school and
even more difficult place than it once
was
in the united states add to these the
economic and political forces that have
reduced school funding while increasing
testing thus cutting the creativity and
freedom of teachers off at the knees
when heather that's me primed her
students for study abroad trips to
panama or ecuador in advance of
embarking with them she was trying to
build not just the academic skills
required for the work but also the
social and psychological ones required
for extended trips outside of anything
most of them had previously experienced
she would ask them what is your
relationship with risk and what is your
relationship with comfort
just because you can say in advance that
you will be okay with the bugs and the
mud than not having access to the
internet doesn't mean that you actually
will be
perhaps most important of all though we
are going to leave ourselves open to
serendipity we cannot know what all will
happen on this trip we're going to go
and some interesting things will happen
those conversations included discussions
of how risk is different in landscapes
that haven't been rendered safe by
liability lawsuits and in which medical
help is far far away
we talked about the hidden hazards of
the jungle rising water tree falls
compared with the familiar ones like
snakes and big cats that people are
primed to be scared of
risk and potential go hand in hand
we need to let children including
college students risk getting hurt
protection from pain guarantees weakness
fragility and greater suffering in the
future
the discomfort may be physical emotional
or intellectual my ankle my feelings my
worldview and all need to be experienced
to learn and grow
the students who we took on study abroad
trips were carefully chosen mature
capable smart and adept
even so the inability to control our
surroundings the intentionality of
succumbing to serendipity when in the
jungle threw many of them into states of
confusion which sometimes manifested as
anger
many of them believed themselves to be
excited about exploration about
discovery but only when it looked and
felt as they'd already imagined
by inculcating in children the sense
that order is always better than chaos
and that being easily counted and
prioritizing doing things that are
easily counted is the honorable way to
go through school and therefore life
many would extrapolate society creates
adults who bristle at the unexpected and
the new
not only doesn't the jungle look or feel
as you are allowed to believe from even
the best nature documentaries but the
people on the streets of panama city or
quito aren't what you think the cloud
forest and the people who called it home
long before the inca or the spaniards
ever arrived will surprise you too as
will everything else if you take your
blinders off and let yourself experience
the world without taking everything so
personally
mostly the world is not about you but
you can learn from it and an education
should allow you to do just that
yeah this is uh
you know it's funny it seems so obvious
that the world is not about you and yet
the
nature of
one's interaction on the internet i
think especially if it's you know if
you're young enough that it is your
developmental experience
reifies the false belief that it is
about you
and
it's um
it's
epistemologically
devastating
right
the ability to understand yourself as a
biased observer and to try to minimize
that is
somewhat dependent on your ability to
understand that your
your centrality to your own perception
is a bad thing and not a good thing yeah
no that and then that's that's right and
that's actually a great segue to i
wanted to talk about a little bit about
um
embodiment as well embodied cognition
and embodied perception and
you know the idea that um
many people have largely i think without
having uh formalized that this is what
they believe in their heads uh that you
can learn sufficiently just by being
passive by taking it in
and um
you know this is one of the
less frequently objections to video
games as a whole as a holistic learning
environment and as we said i think last
week you know neither of us feel that
video games are inherently you know a
negative
um but that the higher the proportion of
your uh your life they take up the more
likely you are to be limited in how you
can how you can understand yourself in
the world and so there's this there's
this classic
pretty immoral i think i think it
couldn't be done today uh research on
learning in kittens from 1963 called
movement produced stimulation and the
development of visually guided behavior
and it's different from actually from
the one that we are more familiar with
um in which
um pairs of kittens from ten litters uh
are
um kept in darkness for all but three
hours a day and then for three hours one
of them is basically harnessed up
and allowed to move and walk and explore
and then the other one is basically on
the other end of like a carousel
um from the one who's harnessed up but
passive and so everything that the one
that the one sees the other sees as well
but the one is actively engaging with
the world in order to interact with it
and uh the second kitten in each case is
um is only passively experiencing it
and those kittens who only passive
experience passively experience but see
everything that the actively engaged
kittens do
are rendered basically helpless and
helpless they they can't they cannot
make sense of their world later on uh
and
there you know there's there's plenty of
work that has followed from that is a
whole you know field called embodied
cognition that recognizes actually that
uh when we are restricted restricted
from moving our own bodies in relation
to the world we find
we find ourselves incapable and often
don't recognize that we are incapable um
so i think i think for me that may be
the most important piece that we also
lack the recognition of our own and
capability
i found
um
so you know
an interesting
piece by a woman named speakerman from
2018 called carousel kittens the case
for a value-based internet of things
uh in which she says human beings are
highly complex biological systems with
an embodied consciousness that develops
intelligence through experience of the
world
technology is making that experience
passive rather than active and so this
is bigger than school this is this is
about you know what what the world is
that we are creating for ourselves but i
would say that school too this model of
school where you sit still and you know
there's a moment to be active and it's
called recess and maybe we'll even skip
recess if we feel like we need to cram
more stuff in to study for the test
is is effectively a way of
assuring us that our children will grow
up incapable of being fully functioning
adults
i i've tried to encapsulate this in the
distinction between knowing how
something is done and knowing how to do
it which sounds like they are synonyms
but they are not right in other words
you you can know a lot about um
how you know you could you could be a an
avid fan of pole vaulting
and never having never have pole vaulted
and the point is you'd be thoroughly
inept at the point you attempted it
because
you know yes you could know a lot about
what makes a good pole vaulter better
than a bad one but the point is
the knowing isn't in the part of you
that is involved in the doing and
the most important thing and i know that
the reason
that you're you're
making this point central here is
that at some level
those who have only received the
information
don't know which part of it is likely to
be false that's right right
you can read a textbook full of stuff
discerning right they don't know what
the truth sounds like and how it sounds
different than
uh fictions that are plausible but not
right
um and it is essential
the ability to you know discernment is
really about that distinction between
the things that are actually true and
the things that only sound true right
that's the important
uh border and
you know we have an educational system
that is obsessed with you know
delivering things in this abstract
form that does not allow you to detect
the distinction
and um
yeah it's a it's a it's an absolute
tragedy i think in some sense
uh you know
you're hitting the nail on the head that
the the passive kitten is a thoroughly
disabled kitten no matter what they've
seen
yes right yes you can have been shown
the world but if you didn't
take yourself around that world and make
decisions uh about how you would engage
it um
you you are just a passive vessel and
your passivity early will
turn you into someone who can only be
passive later you lose your agency you
lose the potential to be an active and
engaged individual in the world and
that's that's what so much of this
embodied cognition research is
is demonstrating which really like like
like with a lot of evolutionary biology
it feels obvious in retrospect and it's
like you know of course of course you
can't separate
humans um you
there there is no
simple duality right there is no split
between mind and body and you can just
you know treat the you know make sure
that your body is functioning and then
focus entirely on your mind they are
engaging one another there are feedback
systems and it will not work neither
will work fully if you treat them as
separate systems
[Music]